good morning good afternoon everyone my
name is mark garner with agilent
technologies and i'm
really delighted to be here today uh for
dr chiang wong's uh
seminar dr wong as ceo of complete
omics um and you know a lot of us have
been
doing or talking about protein quant
peptide quant by uh lcms for a long time
but i think what's been missing what
we've done a lot of good technical work
but what's been missing
is that killer app that really
clinically relevant application that
drives the field forward and i think
you'll agree
that dr wong is going to talk to us
about exactly that that really
clinically relevant
uh killer app uh the title of his talk
is hitting the achilles heel of cancers
with confidence
robust validation of neoantigens and
with that i will turn it over
to dr wong thank you so much for the
introduction
and uh thank you for organizing this
great
event to allow us to present our work
so the topic of today's talk is about
heating vacation of cancers with
confidence robust validation of new
antigens
and again my name is chin wang i'm the
founder and ceo of complete omix
so i will start by briefly introduce
what the human nucleoside antigen
systems
is the human leukocyte antigen system
or hra system is encoded by the mhcg
complex in humans
these cell surface proteins are
responsible for the regulation of the
immune system
and hra gn complex reside in
on a three megabyte stretch within
chromosome 6
and hr gns are highly polymorphic
which means that they have many alleles
allowing them
to fine-tune the adaptive immune system
so there are mainly two uh main systems
for hiv molecules so type 1 hra
corresponds to mhc class 1 and
type type 1 hra present peptides
from inside the cell for example if the
cell is infected by a virus
the hrs system brings the fragment of
the wires to the surface of the
cell so that the cell can be destroyed
by the immune system
these peptides are typically 9 to 12
amino acids long and are produced from
digestive proteins
that are broken down in the proteosome
inside
inside the cell antigens presented by
mhc class 1 attract t lymphocytes
called killer t cell that destroys those
cells
and type 2 hra corresponds to
imxc class 2. type 2 hi
present antigens from outside of the
cell
to t lymphocyte these antigens
stimulate the multiplication of t helper
cells
also called cd4 positive t cells
which in turn stimulates antibody
producing b
cells to produce antibodies to that
specific antigen
self antigens are suppressed by
regulatory t
cells and the peptides that are
presented
by type 2 hra molecules are typically 12
to 25 amino acid long
the major topic of today is about new
antigens
so new antigens are newly formed
antigens
that have not been previously recognized
by immune cells immune systems so
we typically call the tumor neurogens
a name called mana it stands for
mutation associated neural antigens
manas can be presented on tumor cell
surface and can be recognized by t
cells and which is also new antigens is
also
the foundation of all the
recent cancer immunology therapeutic
measures and also those um
immune checkpoint inhibitors such as
ntpd-1 antibodies
are dependent on the effective
recognition of manners
and but despite the importance of this
group of molecules it is a very
difficult to
reliably detect and quantify new
entities
therefore to validate their potential of
being a drug target
in cancer therapeutics field
so we have recently developed a
technology
which we called mana xr basically is a
technology that
could allow us to enrich specifically
the
mhc molecules from the
cell lysate and then to use the new
antigens from the molecule
and then after purification and
fracking of fractionation so we will be
able to detect those molecules and
quantify their
abundance and those types this
technology
is built upon our previous
development of two actually major
technology
one is called mtsrm which is done from
mutation targeted eiserm
and another one is called safe azam
which is
our recent development in 2000
the paper published in 2017 so
the mtsrm is basically
a method to enrich mutant proteins
um from a variety of different samples
and
then followed by the massback detection
of the mutant peptides
so in this technology we actually used
the very commercially available
antibodies
to enrich the proteins that have a
mutation
on itself compared with using mutation
specific
antibodies this approach is very
affordable because you can virtually use
all the
um antibodies that are targeting the y
type
most of the white type versions of the
proteins
use that as the enrichment method and
then you allow the mass back
to detect mutant proteins mutant alleles
basically is to um to
combine the infringement from the very
commercially available antibody
with the ultra high resolution of the
mass back to detect the mutant
peptides and and also
another part of this um of the import
another important part of the mana
platform is that it's called safe srm
which is another development that we
recently um
published in 2000 2018
2017-18 so about a method
that could allow us to detect
uh ultralow amount of peptides
from a variety of different samples
mainly plasma samples
so by combining these two technologies
together
we with further optimizations we
developed this mono enzyme detection
method
so if you think about
if you think about the detection of
new antigens there are really just the
three different
um difficulties that you want to solve
before we actually make a major
improvement the first one is how can you
optimize the enrichment procedure
that you can enrich hiv molecules
and together with the new antigens
peptides
but not either
or not either lysis part not other
fragments of the cells
and also how can you prevent the
antibodies from falling into your
samples therefore to block your
detection sensitivity
and the second big question is how can
you remove the contaminations from the
ip systems
that's to boost up your detection
sensitivity
and the three question which is actually
very unique to new antigen detection is
how can you
stabilize all the peptides that have
chemically unstable residues
so that's those are the three um
technical difficulties that we have
solved in
when we are developing this mana sm
technology
so we first optimized a set of different
ip
based enrichment methods and compared
their efficiency
and compared to their their
cleanness of the arrangement so
we first tried different cross linkers
and the results shown here is only the
part that
that actually uh with the final result
that we optimized we figured that
uh using dmp at 25
millimolar to trace the antibody with
the
beads together with protein gbs
give us the best bending
of the signal give us the strongest
signal
of the of the energy from the antibody
arrangement
and also we tested uh different
ip systems and we we
first used our previous ip systems that
composed of a reaper buffer
and some modifications which at least is
a reference here
on the right side and we compared that
with a particular
with another different protocol that
claimed to be um
the best for the um neutrino arrangement
and also we compared it with a different
protocol
that claimed to enrich the cell membrane
proteins
and we found that our previous method
was able to enrich emergency molecules
at the highest abundance
and then another another another
step is to see what are the best
illusion buffers
that could elude your new antigens
from the bees but still keep the
antibodies keep
all the small fragments of the
antibodies away from your
illusion so we found that
uh using acetic acid at 20 percent
give us the strongest um signal
across a different um alleles
of neuron of this hra molecules
so and also we quantify
the abundance of the monomers and we can
see that
we can the whole method can allow the
arrangement
of as high as 2 microgram monomers in
35 million sw480 cells which is
roughly translate can be translated into
800
000 hr molecules per cell um that
means this number means that our method
is able to enrich
all possible hi molecules from a single
cell
and during the sample preparation
we do the qc of every
step so basically for every
single step of the procedure we save a
little bit of the sample
and analyze the sample loss and the
signal suppression and we found that
there is a significant amount of pad
derivatives that are present in our ip
immunoprecipitation samples and
for showing those signature peaks
and we tried a variety of different
methods
and we found that using a helic
fc based cartridge that give us the best
um clean up efficiency that could allow
us to keep the pipe type
by remove all the polymers
so the method with the three previous
optimizations we established the method
mana as i am and then we tested
um how can we further
solve the issue of peptide
detection so in isom field when you want
to detect a peptide
you actually are able to choose which
peptide
you think are the best to to use as a
target for
each protein therefore you as a
guideline when you design those peptides
you actually want to avoid some
chemically
unstable peptides such as ones with
cysteine such as the ones with methane
because you want to increase first of
all you want to increase your
sensitivity
by seeing most of the peptide sequence
that you want
for example if a peptide sequence has 10
copies
in your sample and it has a massaging
unit
maybe there are
during the summer preparation the
massaging will gradually be oxidized
and if you don't take previous uh
precautions
and in the final detection um there may
be only
two or three mercedes that are as their
native
reduce the form reduce the form and all
other like eight or seven
mercedes are all oxidized therefore you
actually dilute your
detection and making your sensitivity
drop so in order to
solve those issues people develop many
different ways
such as when we do exam detection
people usually just avoid selecting the
peptides
that with assisting or massaging or
other like
chemical like other residues
that are subject to chemical changes um
but for new antigen detection you really
don't have
a good um a lot of options because
the neonatal peptides by definition
needs to be the peptide that flanking
the mutation site
and the mutation side you don't really
have
a lot of options for example keras
mutations
tp53 hotspot mutations those are pretty
fixed site so which leaves you
most of the time no other good choice um
to switch between different sequences
that you want to detect
so in order to make sure that all the
chemically unstable peptides are
actually detectable
we developed another approach which is
called dual reduction
that this approach includes a
reducing reduction event at high ph
with the dtt and then when we before we
send the sample to mass effect detection
we reduce the sample again at low ph
with tsap and through this procedure
we can see a significant amount of
boost um for the for the peptides
abundance after treated with dtt
and tsap i highlighted on this
several of the dramatic values those are
the fault change data
showing the amount that we we can gain
after the d red dural reduction
treatment
so with that we have established the
whole procedure
including the optimized ip system
and also a clean up procedure
to remove all the detergent
contamination from the sample
and also a peptide preserved preserving
procedure to keep all the peptides with
chemically unstable vacuums to be able
to reduce the format
and with those several uh three
three improvements we we built the mana
sm pipeline
and we evaluated recurrent ratio of new
antigen quantity
quantifications and
we can see from this
um table that the average recurrent
ratio
that we can observe from this uh
pipeline
is about 70 which is dramatically
improved from the previous only one to
three percent
uh by previous publications with this
enrichment
with this you reach this kind of
enrichment efficiency
and the recovery ratio we are able to
see
um really little tiny amount of the
sample
and we are able to see new antigens that
are present
at the cell surface at the very low copy
numbers
and here we present the data
of the quantifications of new antigens
from over minor ism pipeline so we can
see that we first
perform the transfection procedures to
transact hr allele together with
vector that expressed the mutant um gn
mutant um new antigens
into the co-7 cells and we measured
abundance
of the presentations of those new
antigens
as the single percent level and the
the most right side column shows the
copy numbers per cell
and with those information we further
quantify the new antigen presentations
from a variety of different
endogenously mutated cells and such as
the lung cancer cell lines
and a couple of um other cell lines that
i listed
here and on the on the left side
so from those data we can see that
the sensitivity of our technology is
able to quantify down to
one copy per cell and
it which is a dramatic improvement over
previous
methods
so i would briefly talk about the
importance of
the work that we did so in recent
years there have been a big
effort in the whole field to try to
optimize
the peptidomics data
that enriched from these hiv molecules
and there have and there have been major
publications which are listed on the
right side of the slide
showing a potential of new antigen
targeted
therapeutic measures so we are
trying to contribute to this entire
campaign
by coming up with this mana sr method
which allowed us to
contribute to two recent publications uh
on
in in in march one is on sense and the
other one is on science immunology
uh with our contribution to uh
to the project led by dr rodrigo singh
in johns hopkins we were able to help
him
build bi-specific antibodies targeting
a common tp50 mutation and also another
bicep
specific antibodies targeting a very
common key rest mutation
with that we are act we are currently
working with six pharmaceutical
companies
to validate their neurological target
for their cancer therapeutics approaches
and on top of this this
seminar we actually are just submitting
a paper
for review describing a new pipeline
that
can directly handle patient tumor
samples
so the current technology we have is
able to analyze new antigens
from down to merely from down to 50
milligram
of a solid tumor so which we think is a
big
improvement that could push the whole
new antigen detection technology
into direct patient care um because we
are very dedicated
to to push up technology to the
um to the most sensitive uh level
because we know that the more sensitive
we can we can our technology can be
the smaller tumor the two smaller tumor
tissue that we can handle
the more patients can benefit from this
from the personalized neurogen-based
therapeutics
previously it has been a big difficulty
to
directly handle patient tumor samples
to evaluate their new antigens usually
you will see the publications with tumor
like hundreds of milligram level
and but those are representing
only a small part of the cancer patients
which are relatively middle to late
staters
the patients who actually are can
benefit most
from from personalized therapeutics
uh actually the early diagnosed uh are
actually the one that can be
early diagnosed so we build up this
a new pipeline that could help to
include more patients
into this potential um
personalized therapeutic approach
so and oh and finally i want to um
demonstrate this show this to you guys
that
we are welcoming any members to join us
with uh um as a team member
and also we are currently offering
new antigen validation services to the
scientific community
and also to the pharmaceutical companies
and if you want to
discuss with us about the collaboration
please send an email to info at
completeomix.com
and
with that i want to uh thank
first of all dr brother volkov who has
been uh my mentor
uh over the years and uh he has been
very supportive to my company
um after uh we were funded and
we are still collaborating on a variety
of different projects
and also i want to thank the
completeomix team
um with our fancy team members that um
make all the improvement of our
technologies and
the third i want to thank agilent
technologies to
um to organize the event and also to
give us
constant support to our research for um
with their platforms with their um
technical
um support and their sentence works with
us and answer all questions all the time
and with that i want to thank you for
um for being here and for um
this to attending this seminar and uh um
i would want to and with that with that
i want to
um start to answer some questions if you
have
and thank you so much for being here
thank you dr wong that was great uh and
we have had a number of questions come
in
um i'll start uh first one
uh someone was asking how long the
entire procedure takes
and about the cost of materials for for
a single assay
um very happy to answer the question the
whole procedure
uh starting from dry cell pallet will
take about
six to seven consecutive days to finish
and it will cost roughly five thousand
dollars
just for the experimental materials to
perform
one essay and the most costly part
will be the antibody and the magnetic
beads and each of them will cost about
two thousand dollars to get we need
yearly high milligram levels
antibodies and uh more than 10 meals of
the magnetic beads
those are the most costly part of the of
the experiment
okay okay great um and
actually a less uh
detailed question but how are you
planning on targeting the cells with
mana peptides
i mean there are um there are so many uh
different ways of uh when you have the
neuroendocrine inflammation
there are so many different ways that
can be um
can be adopted to design a personalized
securities methods people have tried
using
mri vaccine you know to encode those
new antigens and also people tried using
just directly injecting neurogen
peptides uh to human body
and uh also you know just like what we
recently published
uh with dr vogelstein that we used uh by
specific antibodies
to achieve the therapeutic effects
okay excellent excellent and those were
the
the science and the science immunology
papers correct right
yes correct okay great thanks
um do you ever see ptms
on the mana peptides um
that's a great question um we haven't
seen um design a approach to just uh
see the ptm um so far we have been
focusing only on mid sense you know
point of mutations
um you know there are a lot of still a
lot of questions need to be answered
such as
which ones are which the most frequently
mutated human
cancer drama genes which ones are which
mutation which mutations actually
can be presented on cell surface uh i
believe
that next step after we figure out the
completed list
of the frequent new antigens that we
should move forward
into those um pvms that are
uh can be presented on on your antigen
peptides
okay okay excellent
and one fairly detailed technical
question
two parts why do you need double
reduction
do you detect artificial methionine
oxidation
of the reducing agent so
um double reduction uh
the reason is there are two steps that
will actually
in the either the whole procedure that
will actually causing your sample to
lose sensitivity
the first step you know imagine that if
you have a peptide
i mean it's like a the same the same
sequence
but with brothers and sisters who are
modified
at different positions then you will
lose the sensitivity because you're
in let's say you have 10 peptides um
that was supposed to be detected let's
say you have a sensitivity of detecting
five peptides
but you actually have 10 copies of the
peptide yes you can detect it
but if those 10 peptides are
you know becoming 10 different
different derivatives then you won't be
able to detect
any one of them because they become just
one copy
and which unfolds and below your
instrument detection
detectability so we did
a high ph fractionation which is a step
that we
purify the samples and we believe that
if there are different modifications
during the fractionation
the same peptide will be fractioned into
different positions
different fractions of the sample so
therefore we actually
will result in a reduced amount for each
individual fraction
therefore we hope to preserve the
peptide that focus them
into one fraction so therefore we
adopted a dtt
reduction at high ph um that is more in
line with the high-pitched
uh fractionation and then in the mass
spec
analysis it is low ph so um
it still has the same problem if we
don't
if we don't keep the pipelines well
different
derivative the different format of the
same sequence
will actually become different peaks in
the in the
low p in the low lobe online at rcms
so therefore we need to further uh
reducing
to reduce them using the low ph uh
reduction
buffer which is tsap with these two
approaches we are able to
basically refocus all the um
separated peaks into one single peak for
each individual peptide sequence
therefore we can boost up the
sensitivity of the detection
okay great great and uh
uh for determining copy number
uh so the number of copies of the neo
antigen per cell how do you do that
so it's uh first of all we are able to
quantify the new antigen copy numbers
from our sample
and we start and also we have we know
the
uh starting cell number of our sample so
uh
then we divide these two values to
calculate
the copy numbers per single cell it's an
average level
okay okay
great and a question came
in are the antibodies specific to the
mutation
sites oh no uh the antibodies are not
specific to mutation sites
uh we use a universal uh hra
antibody um w632 cologne to enrich
the hre type one molecules uh it's not
neotion specific
it will enrich everything um
from is when you reach all the hiv and
type 1 alleles
molecules and with all the antigens and
your antigens are presented on the
uh on the molecule
okay makes sense and um
how do you search for the neoantigen uh
is there a database or are you doing
genova sequencing yes
so this is basically a targeted
detection so
it's i mean i understand your question
um
so what we believe about
what we believe about multi-ohmics is
basically we need to know the genomic
information
and with that we can more wisely design
a per approach to make our detection
more sensitive
so therefore the presentation today
the technology we are talking about is a
targeted detection approach
where we know those mutations through
genomic sequencing
and we can come up with a list of
possible new antigens
that that could present it potentially
presented on the cell surface
because the mutation site is known and
also you know the length
of the possible neurogenesis is from 9
to 12. i mean some of them are 8 amino
acids but most of them will be 9 to 12
amino acids
you actually can exhaust all possible
new oxygen sequences
for any single point of mutations
we do also do profiling approach to just
share the same sample preparation method
it's just we're using the ob trap
rather than using a triple quad cylinder
trap we can get the complete profile of
all the pipe types
peptide hepatitis data
and um we can do that um but from our
experience
uh most of the data you get from those
profiling approaches
have nothing to do with mutations and
has nothing to do with
um with these new antigens
so therefore the high abundance
unrelated peptides are actually blocking
your sensitivity
from seeing those true valuable new
engines that's why we and also
right now it is so readily available to
sequence a tumor sample
and you need only five percent of the
compared with the the comparison tumor
you
tumor tissue you need for proteomics
approach you probably need only five
less than five percent of tumor tissue
there
to just get a complete coverage of the
whole cancer genome
therefore you you get a lot of genetic
information in hand
uh with that information you design a
more targeted approach
we believe this is more sensitive and
better leverage the knowledge
we know about cancer genomics and
proteomics
right yeah and and we all know how
precious those samples are
and you don't get a lot yeah
yeah actually an interesting question
came in
uh if you think that this detection of
neo-antigens
would work with ffpe samples
that's a great question uh we haven't
tried ffp
samples i think i would imagine that
there could be some issue with the
chemical multi
modifications that are potentially
happening on the peptides
on the neon peptides but we are happy to
to proceed and you know to continue to
do some tests with fipe samples if we
have the resource
okay uh
see um
one last question came in about the
triple quad you're using
yeah we use uh we used uh pre
we have been using agilent triple quad
mass spectrometers and the recent ones
that we are using is the 6495 b and c
and so those are the platform that we
have been using
okay okay um
if anyone else has any questions please
enter them in the
chat um uh another one just came in do
you think neo antigens will have a
better clinical performance than
genomic or mrna molecules
um so it's a great question
so you know the very famous uh the
kawaii 19 vaccine makers um they have
been starting
with actually cancer a new engine
targeted mri
uh vaccines before and so
there are a variety of different reasons
um the results have
not been extremely good so um
but i can but i have seen over the past
year
with a widely used um
widely optimized uh manufacturing
procedure for the kobe 19
vaccination mri vaccines there are a lot
of technical difficulties are being
solved
towards using mri vaccine to other
diseases
so i would imagine that within the
several years
there should be a major improvement in
directly using the mri vaccines to
for cancer vaccinations so those
but but the one of the fundamental
question is which
sequences are actually presented there
could
serve as your target for the vaccination
eventually when the manufacturing method
becomes very mature
it will be more of a market that for
every individual patient you need to
know exactly
what your mutation specific
new antigens are presented so that's why
we develop further into all those
technologies
and we hope one day we can serve as the
first line bef the first line of the
patient's
personalized therapeutic establishment
to
before the patient pays a ton load of
money
for their for their treatment we can
tell them exactly
this is your target and you need to do
this target and
don't use this one don't use this drug
but use this this target this uh
antibody or so that's basically the uh
what we can foresee
in the future in the near future
excellent um another
question um for people who are using
predictive algorithms to predict
neoantigens
have you been able to evaluate the
efficacy of the exome transcriptome
analyses by bioinformatics
that to predict the neoantigens that you
see by your technology yeah that's a
great question
um a lot of people have been working
with prediction algorithms
and from the slide there is a table
showing you the copy numbers um per cell
and you can search the sequences through
emergency
net damage you see and you will get a
general
uh you will see the result that the ones
that actually presented the really high
copy numbers
doesn't correlate to the bending
affinity
that is that pre that's pretty predicted
from those algorithms and and this is
what we are i think the prediction is
good
in terms of the giving you a general
idea about what could be there
and but i i would um
you know buy more on this technology
improvement to finally exhaust
all possible new antigens on the cell
surface
to directly see the sequences
because we have seen that the largely
uncorrelated data
from the from what we can see from the
sales surface
compared with um compared with the
prediction
i think prediction is a good start point
um
to give you some general maybe good
candidates to start validate
um but you but it's great it's much
better
to have the data directly for the direct
observance
and um if i can combine a couple of
questions um
basically sort of what what are the
barriers to actually getting this into
the clinic and
and combining another question with that
do you think you have the sensitivity
now
uh is it just a question of uh
i i don't want to say validation because
that can be a loaded word
uh what what how do you get from here to
there
if you will yeah so it has been a big
question mark
for um putting mass spectrometry based
analysis to directly patient care um but
i believe
this is a new antigen validation
is a good um starting point because
there is a rigid need for the patients
um to have a personalized therapeutics
method
to have therapeutic approaches and i
think
the most difficulty part is the
reproducibility and the sensitivity
how can we come up with a pipeline
that can be reproducible without
regardless of the operator's
experience and regardless where this
machine is located
but still see the same result across
different hospitals
throughout the whole world that's a big
that's a big question
the second question is um how can we see
um the things that are at low amount is
extremely low abundance how can we
uh make ensure our sensitivity of
detection
uh across different um institutions
so that's um the major improvement that
we are making
which which we already submitted paper
is that we are
making an actually independent
instrument
that is able to process all the samples
it turns
from a seven day six day or seven day
approach to a procedure that lasts for
only four hours
and with that we believe that it will
dramatically improve
uh the accessibility of hospitals to the
um
directly analysis of patient tumor
samples
um so that's basically uh
what we are doing and we hope to solve
the reproducibility and sensitivity
issues
yeah excellent excellent and and
certainly automation
as much as throughput is about
reproducibility
and precision yeah great
um another interesting question uh will
tumor suppressor gene mutations produce
neoantigens
uh so tumors we haven't
uh specifically isolate you know
different um
different mutations and uh
i'm sure tumor-specific um mutations
will produce new antigens
on the cell surface so yes
sure
and then so
a question asked do you see a
correlation between
intracellular neoantigen peptide
concentration
and the number presented in the mhc
complex
on the cell surface so we we
didn't uh specifically uh
isolate the intracellular uh nutrient
peptide
but from a numer uh from numerous uh
previous reports um it has been shown
that the intracellular uh
nuance and peptide are less than five
percent of the entire neural antigen
pool
so we are more focused on the cell
surface yeah
yeah okay excellent
excellent and then uh one last question
um sort of and and this is a bit of
prediction
um you know what do you see as being the
ultimate clinical
detection assay is it immuno sm uh
srm or
uh and and that sort of goes back to
what you said earlier about
uh mass spec in the clinical lab
yeah so um i understand um
so i think the the clinical analysis
will be
um the difficulties will actually be the
sensitivity and the reproducibility
so it's not very much mutation uh
variable mutation specific so um
uh we i think um
let's say within i we believe that
within
one or two years there should be a
relatively comprehensive list of all the
major
uh java genes mutations that are that
can be
potentially presented so with that
information
we could establish targeted detection
approaches
and with further improvement on the
sensitivity
for each particular patient that has a
matched mutation
and i think it's possible to directly
use some
um antibodies that are antibodies that
are recognizing the
um new antigens on cell surface directly
use those antibodies to do diagnosis
i think it's possible but it will depend
on
um establish the knowledge of a good
list
of very solid presenters and
a good um establishment
of a good library of antibodies
that are very specifically reacting
those
reacting to those new antigen sequences
those well actually later i think this
will take
years several years to develop but
so far we we have been focusing on
polishing our technology to make it more
and more sensitive
therefore we can achieve that
final solution um you know faster and
faster so
yeah okay excellent and
i think with that we will wrap it up and
first and foremost i want to thank you
dr wong for a
fascinating and very stimulating
presentation
uh i want to thank the audience this was
a great discussion far more
uh than we had hoped really insightful
questions
um remind everyone that this
presentation
will be on the on-demand side on
labyrinth
you can continue to submit questions to
the on-demand
and we will try and get those answered
and
i think with that we can wrap up
and i will thank you all for attending
and
hope that you enjoy your days thank you